You already know what's goin' on.
It's EarthGang in the building bro.
We doin' Road Rotation
with Bleacher Report.
-Road Rotation.
- Look at all these kicks.
I got examples of the kicks on deck.
- Buy these Nikes boy.
- Pockets cheesecake.
- These Yeezys boy.
- Tune in.
- B/R Kicks.
EarthGang, man, Road Rotation, boy
don't get it twisted.
Well this is what I chose to show today.
Some chill s***.
Let's see, if we on tour for two months
I'll probably have, like, three to four
rotation changes in that time.
Out of these pair of kicks the only things
that lasted the longest is these Dsquared2s
and these been through a lot.
But, I don't give a f*** what they've been through.
I love 'em.
They cost me like 1,600 bucks
at the Dsquared2 store here in SoHo.
it was my first time going shopping in SoHo.
So it was my birthday
Imma go out and buy me somethin'.
I bought me some Dsquared2s
and they got the fur on the side
they got the fur on the inside
they got the multiple different laces
they got the strap.
It's just a lot going on with this shoe
but I love it.
They been through a lot
they been all over the world with me
and I love 'em with all my heart.
But then you come up on some new s***
like these are relatively new, these Guccis.
These, like I said, we just got these from Nike
for the Fruit Ski, shoutout to Nike, Nike.
What's crazy about these is the inside, like
you see all this s***?
- So, like, this part of the shoe will
never be seen, yo, like, this
does not come off.
The soles got art on it,
it says, "Our solar system."
Oh it got the planets, Mercury, Venus.
Clove hitch, this is dope.
To put art on the inner sole
reclaim your sole ladies and gentlemen.
So yeah, shoutout to Nike for these.
- These, like, some everyday, everythings.
You know, I never go wrong with the little
Vapor Max bubble s***. That s***, I be—
I got another little pair that I use
for my workout shoes.
for my, like, day to days.
These are just comfortable as f***.
- These are the OG Bo Jacksons, Bo knows
Huaraches and these are my workout shoes.
You can't leave home without your workout shoes.
Ready to go get some pushups, do your exercise
whatever you want to do. Blow off some steam.
- These are actually intended to be workout shoes.
These is the Alexander Wang's workout shoe.
That's what they said at the store, but I'm
probably not gonna wear 'em for that purpose.
They have fun at Alexander Wang so, you know
what I'm sayin', that's cool.
It's an Alexander Wang x Adidas collab.
This is for, like, his workout line.
I'm like, "Ain't nobody workin' out in
none of these things that you droppin', but
we are gettin' 'em and they do look good."
- We just got these, these ACGs from Nike.
These are super comfortable.
I put these on yesterday after I got offstage
from wearing these and, like, I usually
will walk around with my boots
but I was like, "I'm not wearing'
no boots after the show."
And these, my foot slid right in these joints.
They snug, they super comfotable man
and these definitely some running shoes.
- I got these in two different colors.
These is my, like, alternative to, like, gettin'
off stage and, like, walkin' around.
Super soft, super cushiony.
These Kappa, Kappa slides.
I just like the—you know, I like some
bright-ass slides when I'm walkin' around.
I don't know if y'all know the company
called Chinatown Market.
Everybody got, like, discount mobs and swap meets
or whatever, it look like some swap meet
variety type s***, but when you put 'em on
and especially when you get on a stage
and lights are reflecting off of these...
- Disco ball joints.
Exactly, it's a whole different vibe.
People, you can't really even see my feet
in the pictures, it's just like shininess
you know what I'm sayin', in the pictures.
So I f*** with it for that aspect.
- I usually start out with what shoes I want
to perform in.
I just like the craziest shoes sometimes.
Sometimes I pick, like—
like these are amazing.
These remind me of some shoes
that I took to Rolling Loud, like, some
snow boot kinda joints.
I usually have these snow boots
that I had been rockin' for, like, two
or three tours.
They actually motorcycle ridin' boots, but
people think they snow boots just because
they so durable and stuff.
Every time I hopped on stage with 'em
the fans would go crazy, like, you know
what I'm sayin', "Oh, what are those!
Ahh, what you doin'."
So, that's the reaction that you want to
get from the people.
So, whatever it takes.
I like wearin' shoes that makes people
you know what I'm sayin', that gets
reactions out of people.
You can say what you want about Kanye West
but he makes great f***in' shoes.
These, like, kinda go with everything, so—
and, like, when you tour a lot you go
through all types of terrain, you know
what I'm sayin', like, it's rainin' here, it's
snowin' here, dusty here.
So, you want somethin' that you can just
slip in and out and get to where you goin'
without damaging your other shoes.
So these I wear a lot because
these take the beating.
OK?
Kanye West can handle the beating.
- These were $1,600, bro, when I bought 'em.
That was the most I ever spent on a shoe
in my life and I will never do that again.
- I will never spend more than $1,000
on a pair of shoes.
These were, like, $600.
This is the most.
- These Dsquared2 boots, I think retail
was, like, 14, with tax they ended up being
almost, damn, 16. So that was—
It was the most expensive shoe
I ever, ever, ever, ever got
and they don't look like it no more
and I don't give a f***, but they are
super durable and they are my favorite shoes.
Like, I don't care what they go through
what they end up lookin' like—the laces have
you know what I'm sayin', all type of stuff
has happened to 'em, but
they are my favorite ones.
- For me it was these, these Yeezys
was, like, $600, you know what I'm sayin'
but, like, I haven't seen nobody with
a pair of these on.
Like, to me it's not really about
how much they cost.
It's just about how rare they are.
That's all I really care about
is really, like, am I gonna see anybody else in this?
If not, that's exactly what I want.
I don't care about name brands
or none of that stuff.
I remember the first tour we was on
when, like, we pulled up on the Nike office
and it was all of us.
It was us, it was J.I.D.
We all was on this same little tour together
our first time ever getting anything for free
and we all just walked out with so many boxes.
Nobody wants to carry three boxes of anything.
You know what I'm sayin', like?
- And the boxes don't fit in your suitcase.
- If I was an at home person, yeah, but
this is Road Rotation.
- All you need is a bag.
- Road Rotation, that's the whole point.
That's what it is, the whole point.
- Don't take a box on the road.
- Yeah, straight up. Straight up.